- People have been getting tattoos
since day one for a reason.
Some do it for expression and identity.
Some do it just because it's cool
which in my mind is just as valid.
Some people use them as mementos
and others get tattoos
to heal painful memories.
Come here, come on.
My name is Brian Finn.
I've been tattooing for 20
years here in Toledo, Ohio.
Alexa, ask Delta to fill dog bowl.
(water splashing)
I think what I like most about tattooing
and what drew me to it was the freedom.
In 2015, I decided that
I was gonna come in
on of my days off
and tattoo over scars that were
caused by human trafficking,
self-harm, and domestic violence.
- I wouldn't be who I am
today without my past.
I started cutting when I was 17.
I felt like it was the only way
to feel things sometimes
when I had numbed myself
to the point where I
wasn't feeling anything.
It got really bad in my early 20s
and that's when most
of these scars are from
that will be tattooed over today.
- I think that I'm helping people
by finishing that chapter in their lives.
They can go onto the next.
They don't have a daily reminder.
Alexa, ask Delta to fill one cup.
(water whooshing)
- I think I'm really getting
to a place in my life
where I'm moving past those things
and really comfortable with who I am
and I'm comfortable in my own skin.
- Alrighty, here we go.
- I think that having the
dragonfly on my forearm
will help remind me that
I have built this future
for myself and I have
transformed and I am realizing
who I'm meant to be
and I think that it will
help by covering the scars
to avoid that trigger a little bit,
that feeling of wanting the pain again.
It's about building more positive memories
and building a life worth living.
Dragonflies symbolize transformation
and self realization.
I'm building on the past
and building a new life
for myself and transforming
and something beautiful
can grow from the pain.
- I think I choose to take the time
to help people out
because a lot of people
don't take the time
to help people out.
So, anyone that is looking for a tattoo
for whatever reason, I'll be here.